how's it going everybody it's warm
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU it's been a while but today we have
some Deadpool 3 news and today we have
news about the plot of Deadpool 3 what
Ryan Reynolds has pitched Disney for the
next film in what could only be
described as genius it's the perfect
plot that would not only be extremely
satisfying to see but would actually
make the most sense to do based on all
of the new characters coming to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe from Fox this
plot would help clear everything up and
make it to where there's not really that
much confusion in the new Marvel
Cinematic Universe which means that
Deadpool 3 would be a movie not only
involving the old Fox characters
including the x-men but would also
involve current MCU characters and new
MCU characters that are upcoming as well
so let's dive into Ryan Reynolds's
awesome idea for the next Deadpool film
but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU and so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a Wolverine a Funko pop to
enter all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
down below
so today's leak comes from a Marvel
insider who has been right about many
many things in the past especially when
it came to Avengers endgame everything
that he leaked ended up coming true and
many of you know who he is we've talked
about him several times on this channel
and it is Roger at Wardell and in a
recent tweet he has revealed what
exactly Deadpool 3 could be about he
said Deadpool kills Fox's Marvel
Universe was one of the ideas pitched by
Ryan Reynolds back in 2019 now this is
something that Marvel Comics has
actually kind of done before they did a
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe book
this book was not canon to any of the
comics or any of the stories but it did
happen and basically Deadpool goes on a
huge killing spree killing people such
as the entire Fantastic Four team and
even who ought to The Watcher it's kind
of more of a horror story than anything
else but that's not exactly what Ryan
Reynolds has pitched for the next
Deadpool instead what Ryan Reynolds has
simply offered is a chance to clean up
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in a
hilarious way as most people know by now
the Disney Fox deal resulted in all of
Marvel's characters coming
to Disney and Marvel Studios including
all of the x-men the fantastic foreign
characters like Galactus and Doctor Doom
etc which means that none of the x-men
films including Dark Phoenix x-men
apocalypse and all the other ones that
people don't like too much never
happened in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the stories that happened in
the Fox universe basically didn't happen
however that could be quite confusing as
new characters such as Professor X
magneto Cyclops beast all of them start
to enter the Marvel Cinematic Universe
unless it's made clear by somebody that
these old characters are now basically
dead they don't exist
all of the old Fox x-men characters are
gone we aren't going to see them in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and what
better way to clear this up and kill off
all of these characters than to have
Deadpool do it a character who can break
the fourth wall and really explain what
he's doing he could say things like oh
I'm over at Marvel Studios now I made it
to the MCU but these guys didn't so I
gotta kill him just to make sure there's
no confusion about who made it over and
who didn't and this doesn't even have to
be the entire plot point to the movie
but nonetheless would be hilarious and
it would also offer the clarity to some
people who might be a little bit
confused about who's coming over to the
MCU and who's not now we know that Ryan
Reynolds has met with Marvel Studios at
least a few times already to talk about
Deadpool and on the live with Kelly and
Ryan show he even admitted that they're
over at Marvel Studios now he said we're
working on it right now with the whole
team we're over at Marvel now which is
the big leagues all of a sudden it's
kind of crazy so Ryan Reynolds has
already mentioned that they are working
on Deadpool 3 already now another part
of this tweet by Roger Wardell was that
Michael Bay may direct the Deadpool
movie and this doesn't come as that big
of a surprise as Ryan Reynolds has
recently worked with Michael Bay in
Netflix is six underground which was
also written by the Deadpool writers
Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick so
basically the Deadpool team has recently
just worked with Michael Bay so it's
very possible that they could have
talked about him directing the next
Deadpool film not to mention that before
the Transformers movies Michael Bay used
to be pretty tight with Disney so it is
possible but who would like to see
Deadpool kill off the old x-men Fox
universe I personally think it's a
genius idea
I'd love to see him clear all of that up
and I'd love to hear what he would have
to say as he's going around killing
everybody breaking the fourth wall but
let me know what you all would think
about this and the comments down below
would you like to see this happen in
Deadpool three let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU for live updates you
can follow me on Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof